there may be trouble ahead for Alex
kurtzman as the relationship between
secret hideout and Paramount is perhaps
more strained than we realize and this
might mean that actually Starfleet
Academy is not as guaranteed as we
thought
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
just over a week ago I told you guys
about some information I was given by a
source I speak to this Source actually
works for a marketing company that had
been doing some outsourced work for
Paramount he was basically saying that
from what he inferred from the
conversation he had with some Paramount
Executives that they were very very keen
for a Talus to be the future of Star
Trek and not Alex kurtzman but then last
week we get the news dropped that
actually there's going to be another
live-action series staff Fleet Academy
and the Alex kurtzman will be co-show
running that show now this was a
surprise to lots of people including me
because it goes against everything we've
been hearing four months we have had
lots and lots of rumors that actually
the relationship between Paramount and
Alex kurtzman were strained I've been
hearing very personal things about Alex
kurtzman that I don't really want to
share but one main room that I've heard
again and again and again is that Alex
kurtzman makes big promises and doesn't
always follow through and that certain
elements at Paramount just don't trust
him
so how did he get Starfleet Academy
green lit well one of the rumors and
again this is not confirmed we don't
know this for certain but one rumor was
and this was actually rumor before
stafflet Academy was announced that
actually he was going to struggle to get
Starfleet Academy green lit because
Paramount were very interested in
section 31 and they kind of wanted these
two shows to go together
if he couldn't get section 31 with
Michelle yo then it was very unlikely he
was going to get Starfleet Academy
a rumor and again this is just a rumor
is that he got Michelle yo or at very
least that's why he told Paramount
so again One Source in marketing is
telling me he was amazed by this another
source that actually works at a big
agency in Hollywood with all the actors
and everything else said to me he was
amazed when this was announced he said
there were no Whispers on the Grapevine
about Starfleet Academy he said a show
like this as big as this they would have
heard something the agents at the moment
are all over big shows like this because
they're desperate for that next big
thing they are desperate for contracts
to get signed they want deals for their
guys
so the fact that Paramount basically
kept this quiet was a shock now this
Source actually also told me that six
months ago they genuinely believed
Stafford Academy was coming but it had
gone so quiet it was just believed it
had been canceled
mainly because again this rumor about
the Michelle yeoh thing as soon as
Michelle Yoda won that Oscar she became
one of the hottest properties in
Hollywood for the next four or five
years my guy says she will be able to do
pretty much whatever she wants that is
the power of winning the Oscar
so the general belief was that why would
she do Star Trek when she can do
literally whatever she wants but then it
was dropped just over a week ago that
Starfleet Academy had been greenlit but
the date was unusual because it was the
end of March early April nearly a week
before a big Starfleet anniversary April
the 5th is first Contact day it is the
day that zephron Cochrane took the
Phoenix for the first warp flight the
Vulcans that were passing by noticed him
and come down and we had first contact
with the Vulcan race the first contact
with any alien race this was a big day
and trackies adoring you only have to go
on Twitter or other groups yesterday to
see all the memes flying around
so again speaking to the marketing guy
he told me look if they've announced
this a week before first Contact day
they must have Michelle yo and they must
have uh ready to go plan for section 31
because it makes no sense to announce
Starfleet Academy a week before a big
anniversary date like that in the Star
Trek calendar you would announce it on
April 5th and people would go crazy
but he didn't he did it a week before
so my guy's saying he must have Michelle
yo in the bag and they're going to
announce it on Wednesday because that's
the only thing that makes sense
but Wednesday came and went and we had
no announcement and nothing from
Paramount
except
The Whisper started again people that
work in the industry talking to me about
things they've heard so these are people
that work directly with Paramount these
are people that work directly with some
of the biggest marketing firms and some
of the biggest talent agencies in
Hollywood
they are saying that actually the
relationship between Alex kurtzman and
secret hideout and Paramount is strained
that actually they would really like
Star Trek to be led in the future by
Tara metallis but it's actually Alex
kurtzman for this kind of being
resistant to that Paramount of
absolutely adored the response to the
Picard season 3 has got and they're
looking at that and saying look that's
what make trekkies happy look at the now
huge campaign that is going on to get
staff Trek Legacy on the cards but again
it's Alex kurtzman that's being
resistant to that another thing is that
Alex kurtzman has been quite quiet about
the success of Picard season 3. he
hasn't really got involved with any of
the press briefings etc etc he's allowed
Terry matalis to really push that is
there a reason for that
but we're going to talk about Star Trek
Legacy and why we can't have it in
another video let's just focus for a
second on that nothing was announced for
First Contact Day
it makes no sense to me and I don't work
in marketing it makes no sense to me
that it would stuff that Academy was
announced when it was
the person that I talk to that does work
with marketing said this is marketing
101. it's this it's borderline stupid
that they did it this way and actually
the marketing people at Paramount are
apparently Furious so what do we think
is going on Alex skirtsman may have
overstated his hand when it comes to
having section 31. he was using section
31 and Michelle yeoh to leave getting
the TV shows that he wanted he was going
to co-show run Starfleet Academy
but it was section 31 that he was really
excited about he wants to do section 31
with Michelle yo he wants to show on it
and he wants to direct it that is the
show that he's really really excited
about we have seen him talking to
reporters about this more than one
occasion
but
he may be bluffed a little bit and maybe
didn't have Michelle yo quite in the bag
now that doesn't mean he won't
but he may have overstated how close
they were to having a deal when they
announced Starfleet Academy
with the plan being to then announce
section 31 on First Contact Day the fact
that that hasn't happened really is the
proof we need to suggest that maybe this
wasn't planned out as well as it could
have been
what I'm hearing and what I've been
hearing generally for months still
stands Alex kurtzman really is walking a
very fine line
because the contract that he cast
currently with Paramount does run out in
just over a year
the current contract he has actually
apparently doesn't really say anything
exclusively about Star Trek so Paramount
could go with a different company for
Star Trek if they need to even though
contractually that might be relatively
complicated
but what does all this mean for
Starfleet Academy is it definitely going
to happen
one person I've spoken to that is
reasonably close to this actually
laughed when I suggested that it was
there is absolutely no guarantee the
Starfleet Academy is going to happen
and he said to me just look at what
happened with Star Trek IV it was
announced it was greenlit the actors
scratched their heads and went do we
know about this and then it went very
very quiet and quietly basically got
canceled
Starfleet Academy might go exactly the
same way guys I would love to know
exactly what you think about this get in
the comments and tell me what you're
thinking is Starfleet Academy something
you even want does it make any sense
that they have announced this the way
they have and would you be bothered in
the scientist if it did get canceled but
mainly guys I want to know what you
think about Star Trek Legacy everybody I
speak to says that's the show they want
they want a continuation aboard the
Titan with seven of nine as Captain I'd
love to know if any of you are actually
think that's a bad idea or all of you
like me thinking that's the future of
Star Trek get in the comments and tell
me exactly what you think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also go and check out the description
where there are links to loads of
Sidetrack related stuff including our
Twitter page Facebook page and Discord
server where you can go and speak to
like-minded sci-fi Geeks also there's
our patreon page where if you want to
for a small contribution each month you
can see most of our videos first and
without the adverts and it supports the
channel
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign
[Music]